Traduttore: Susanna Tagliabue
Revisore: Beatrice Chiamenti
Ho vissuto i miei primi diciassette anni
in modo meraviglioso
partite a calcio all'oratorio,
grandissimo divertimento
con gli amici, con la famiglia,
tanto studio...
quello veramente no,
ma tanta voglia di lavorare.
A quell'età ero già artigiano
professionista con mio padre
e quelle poche risorse in più
che avevo mi hanno permesso
di acquistare questa moto nel 1989:
un sogno, veramente,
per pochi miei coetanei.
In quel momento, ricordo benissimo
di avere quella convinzione di tenere
completamente la vita nelle mie mani
poter decidere in ogni momento
cosa far accadere nella mia vita
ma, soprattutto, cosa non fare
accadere nella mia vita.
Il 28 agosto 1990 quella convinzione
si è completamente sgretolata
a causa di un incidente motociclistico
contro una vettura,
che mi ha fatto completamente
perdere la gamba
e cambiare, di conseguenza, la mia vita.
Mi sono svegliato il giorno dopo
con una gamba in meno
e tantissimi sogni cambiati.
In quel momento,
in quel letto di ospedale,
in quei cinque mesi di degenza
dopo l'incidente,
una domanda era: è veramente finita?
È la fine di una vita meravigliosa
o, addirittura,
è una nuova opportunità di vita,
per renderla ancora più straordinaria?
Mi son trovato i primi
importanti obiettivi
Questa è una foto che ritrae quel momento,
a distanza di circa 10 mesi,
dove una manifestazione di 54 chilometri,
la preparazione e la partecipazione
in soli dieci mesi
mi ha fatto veramente capire
che il successo della mia vita,
dal punto di vista familiare,
sportivo e lavorativo,
non sarebbe stato determinato
dal numero delle mie gambe,
ma da tutto ciò che avevo nella testa.
Da lì sono arrivati i primi traguardi,
La perdita di una gamba a 17 anni
non mi ha mai fatto perdere
la voglia di vivere,
la voglia di fare sport.
In ogni momento che ho vissuto
c'era proprio la voglia di ritornare,
ritornare a correre,
ma soprattutto di superare veramente,
al cento per cento, la mia disabilità.
Ho portato la protesi per 10 anni
mi hanno sempre garantito che
sarei ritornato la persona di prima
ma, con una disabilità come la mia,
puoi rendere comunque
meravigliosa la vita,
ma non sarai mai la persona di prima.
Man mano che passavano i mesi e gli anni
mi rendevo conto che la mia vita
non era più quella di prima
e che dovevo concentrarmi
su ciò che mi era rimasto
anziché su ciò che avevo perso.
Ho rinunciato alla protesi,
c'è stato un lungo
persorso di accettazione
perchè avere sempre
gli occhi addosso non è facile
ma, soprattutto,
l'accettazione di rinunciare
per sempre alla possibilità
di ritornare a correre
come fa ognuno di voi.
Finché la potenza dei nostri sogni
io sono un grandissimo sognatore
la potenza dei nostri sogni,
dei nostri pensieri,
di come comunichiamo con noi stessi
mi ha permesso, in questi 26 anni,
di raggiungere obiettivi
straordinari nel lavoro.
Una barriera mentale
che mi avevano installato
siccome mi mancava una gamba,
non avrei più trovato la fidanzata
Ho una moglie bellissima,
due figlie straordinarie
E da lì poi sono arrivati
degli obiettivi importanti sportivi
dove il paratriathlon
- nuoto, bici e corsa -
mi ha regalato poi la soddisfazione
di ritornare a correre con le stampelle
e vincere anche una medaglia
d'argento ai campionati europei
È arrivata l'avventura nel ciclismo,
le avventure estreme sulla strada
carrozzabile più alta del mondo,
è arrivata la Parigi-Brest.
Tutte manifestazioni, gare,
occasioni, eventi nella mia vita
che mi hanno fatto capire
che era giunto il momento
di intraprendere questo percorso
di crescita personale
e soprattutto portarlo alle altre persone.
È iniziato il percorso
di crescita personale
che mi ha fatto diventare un mental coach
professionista da due anni.
In questo percorso,
assieme ad altri quattro o cinque amici
abbiamo creato Progetto 22
per vari motivi,
pilastro fondamentale
le ventidue risorse.
Condividendo le nostre storie,
ci siamo resi conto
che un evento nell'età dai 14 ai 20 anni
aveva completamente cambiato la vita
che, se non interpretato
in modo potenziante, costruttivo,
l'avrebbe potuta distruggere,
ma ci siamo trovati,
in una fascia d'età
dai 40 ai 55 anni,
ad avere delle vite meravigliose.
Perciò, un progetto dedicato ai ragazzi,
il cui elemento fondamentale,
il pilastro più grande,
è quello delle risorse.
Ciò che ci ha permesso veramente
di uscire pienamente da questo evento
sono state, appunto,
le nostre risorse.
Abbiamo voluto creare
un sogno utopistico per noi,
quello del Giro d'Italia formativo.
Eventi formativi nelle scuole al mattino
e, nel pomeriggio, coprire la distanza
in sella alle nostre bici,
da un istituto all'altro.
Cioè tappe da 70, 80 e 100 km ogni giorno
io uso sempre il plurale
perché è un progetto nato da tutti noi
anche se poi al pomeriggio in bici
sotto il sole, acqua, nebba e grandine
sono sempre io da solo.
Eh si... invito sempre
anche gli studenti ma...
(Applausi)
Me le vado anche un po' a cercare!
Adesso, però, ho capito
che devo accorciare le tappe
anziché farle a 110 km,
e soprattutto non fare tappe
come Napoli-Roma, di quasi 200.
Quella me la sono proprio
andata a cercare.
È un sogno utopistico,
ma in cui credevamo tanto
l'abbiamo proposto a tantissime persone
non abbiamo avuto tantissimi consensi,
ma il desiderio e la voglia
di partire con l'edizione zero
e poi creare le altre
ci ha permesso, in febbraio,
di concludere la terza edizione
e raggiungere,
direttamente nelle scuole,
oltre dodici mila ragazzi.
Queste sono le nostre 22 risorse.
È un progetto che porteremo avanti.
22 risorse fondamentali
per ognuno di noi,
sono quelle che abbiamo scelto noi,
ma ce ne sono tantissime altre.
Come scoprire le nostre risorse?
Molte volte siamo concentrati
sulle cose, durante la giornata,
che potevano andare meglio
l'interrogazione, il voto,
il contratto e tante altre cose
quando, invece, se ci concentriamo
sulle cose meravigliose
che durante la giornata accadono
scopriamo che noi in quei momenti
abbiamo veramente messo
in campo le nostre risorse,
e cosa ci impedisce di riscoprirle?
Il fatto di essere focalizzati
sui nostri miti,
vedere trasmissioni dove ci sono
l'eccellenza del canto, della recita,
vedere i film
quando in quel momento
vediamo solo l'apice dell'iceberg,
vediamo solo la punta
del lavoro che c'è stato dietro
e dobbiamo essere consapevoli
che noi, come loro, abbiamo
al nostro interno le risorse
e abbiamo anche i loro talenti,
talento che va, ogni giorno,
nutrito con le nostre risorse.
Come fare a scoprirle?
Una tecnica molto pratica:
andare a vedere quello che, già oggi,
facciamo di straordinario
nella nostra vita.
Può essere, come dice sempre un mio amico,
anche la casalinga che fa il risotto
che mangiamo alla domenica
io non sono capace di farlo
perciò capire veramente
le risorse che mette lei in campo,
capire perché siamo
benvoluti dai nostri amici,
in ambito lavorativo, in ambito sportivo,
in quel momento noi
mettiamo in campo
e utilizziamo le risorse
sappiamo di averle dentro di noi
e, in quel momento, di poterle mettere
in tutte le nostre altre abilità.
Perché scoprirle?
Perché ci permettono di scoprire poi
il nostro percorso unico di vita.
Perché questo sassofono?
Uno, perché l'ho suonato per otto anni,
ma ho voluto simboleggiare, oggi,
la situazione che c'è in italia
almeno rimaniamo nel nostro Paese
dei ragazzi rimasti
un po' demotivati,
forse anche noi adulti
abbiamo una responsabilità.
Questi incontri servono,
appunto, per stimolarli
nella fiducia in se stessi,
nella motivazione
e nel ritrovare la propria autostima.
Quel cavalletto, proprio
di fianco al sassofono,
per simboleggiare che
la soluzione non è lontanissima
può essere veramente lì a fianco.
Perciò, mi viene da rivolgermi
ai dirigenti, agli insegnanti:
pensate se gli incontri formativi
che facciamo noi, come Progetto 22,
fossero una cosa
diffusissima in tutta Italia,
a quante opportunità e
quanti strumenti daremmo
in più di quello che
già date ai nostri giovani.
Poi mi rivolgo a voi genitori
sono genitore anche io
se stiamo già veramente facendo
tutto del nostro meglio
per il bene dei nostri ragazzi
o a volte veniamo un po' avvolti,
un po' colpiti dall'egoismo
di raggiungere i nostri obiettivi
anziché quelli dei nostri ragazzi.
E poi mi rivolgo proprio a voi ragazzi
perché vi è stata donata la vita,
avete l'opportunità
e un'età di poter creare
della vostra vita quello che volete.
I vostri sogni, i vostri pensieri
per il momento sono nella vostra testa,
ma, mettendo in campo le risorse
e continuando a sognare
e coltivare i vostri talenti,
nella vostra vita si realizzeranno
sicuramente tutti i vostri sogni.
Questo è quello che, con Progetto 22,
desideriamo fare.
Grazie.
(Applausi)